another man who was relentlessly
maligned on false grounds as Michael
capito he was also an advisor to the
Trump campaign and he joins us tonight
Michael thanks very much for coming on
you've been sharing with us through the
course of this what it's like to be you
and I wonder looking back now that you
have been in effect vindicated you were
not working another was anyone working
for the US government for rather the
Russian government how do you how do you
feel well I do feel vindicated but you
know I spent Tuesday at the police
station in my little village in western
New York pressing charges against
someone for threatening me on facebook
you know this has not ended yet you know
I'm pretty sure that the rest of us you
know the you know Carter page and JD
Gordon the rest are all suffering the
same slings and arrows I am you know we
may have been vindicated by the mauler
investigation but where I don't know
where we're gonna get our reputations
back so I mean what can you do see I
mean you've lost years of your life your
family as you've told us before has been
besieged you can't work a normal job
because of this is there anything that
you can do to make it right at this
stage well I think that I can I can try
to help the the federal government the
Republican Party in the Senate try to
uncover what really happened here I mean
I'd love to get back to work I'm
contacting my old clients who had to
leave me because of this mark on my
record but now that I'm vindicated you
know I I'm well I really want to get
back to work and make money for my
family I really want to inspire some
significant change in the special
counsel law in other ways so people
don't go through this again I love
Carter's by the way Carter's optimism I
just a little bit more angry than he is
I think well I'm angry just watching it
I've got I mean I was only denounced as
a Russian spy once by a buffoon that
chairman of the house in cell company I
can't imagine what your life has been
like I've thought of you this whole time
so congratulations anyway because this
is whether it feels like it or not a
vindication I just want to say one thing
Tucker a pardon general Flynn pardoned
George papadopolis and pardoned Roger
stone right now missing
that's exactly right couldn't growth I
could don't wait till after the election
do it now they deserve it now do it
right now do it do it right now on
Twitter I agree I agree Michael you
think we blow some minds wouldn't it